de bratislava comment voit-on la france
la france aux prises avec la pandémie
quelle image avez vous alors moi en tant
que français je suis assez inquiet je
pense que je peux discuter avec certains
amis et collègues slovaques qu'ils
comprennent que en fait en france
l'image commencé pour vraiment s'immisce
dans la vie des personnes jusqu'au
domicile
moi qui suit les informations de ce qui
se passe en france
j'entends donc on peut parler de porter
les masques à la maison donc on a
l'impression qu'on me demande vraiment
aux personnes et on leur dise qu'ils
doivent faire ce qu'ils doivent pas
faire on se maquille on arrive quand
même à je dirais à faire confiance à la
responsabilité de chacun des individus
et donc de respecter les consignes mais
en france on a vraiment l'impression ou
est par exemple on nous parlait tout à
l'heure du duo de la répression
c'est une impression très forte en
france qui est visible qui fait l'écho
et qui n'est pas du tout cas bratislava
où on peut pas non plus demander
l'attestation justement à 99% des
populations qui est négative donc ce qui
se passe en france est assez inquiétant
[Musique]